well it's a cliche at this point but no
less true that in our culture today the
demand for racism far exceeds the supply
there's no denying that fact and it's
equally obvious that the same rule
applies to other well-worn isms like
sexism there's a huge demand for sexism
but very little of it to be found so
those in search of this elusive resource
must resort to increasingly Desperate
Measures they must look under every Rock
and every nook and cranny and crevice
they must plunge into the deepest
Caverns torches in hand looking for ways
to be persecuted by a patriarchy that is
seemingly nowhere to be found and if
they still can't find sexism in any of
those places then they are forced to
find it at the Oscars which brings us to
the most excruciatingly stupid outrage
cycle of this new year um one stupid
enough that by December of 2024 it may
still remain in the top five stupidest
outrage cycles of the year then again
all signs are pointing towards this
being an especially stupid year so the
competition will be pretty tough but in
any event the Academy Award nominees
were announced yesterday and I I read a
list of the nominees and as expected I I
have not seen 95% of the films nominated
I haven't heard of 70% of the
95% um Oppenheimer which of course I
have heard of led the way with 13
nominations something called poor things
got 11 nominations Martin scor s's
14-hour epic about evil white people The
Killers of the flower Moon scored 10
nominations meanwhile Barbie acquitted
itself quite well uh and much better
than it deserved to with eight
nominations
eight nominations seems like a very
respectable tally but it was not good
enough for the crowds on social media
especially because although Barbie was
nominated for eight Awards Greta Gerwig
was not nominated for best director and
Margot Robbie Barbie herself was not
nominated for best actress why not well
probably because Oscar voters felt that
other people happened to be more
deserving of an award uh and maybe also
because eight nominations for a toy
commercial is already embarrassing
enough for the Academy Awards 10 would
be over the top um so there are many
potential reasons but the outraged
masses settled on their own explanation
which is that this is all due to sexism
of course the Daily Mail reports quote
Fury is mounting on social media after
Margot Robbie and Greta Gerwig were
snubbed for Oscar nominations for their
film Barbie the omissions attracted
extra attention on the account of the
fact that Ryan Gosling who played Ken
did get nominated for best supporting
actor some social media commentators
leapt to point the at sexism quote Ryan
Gosling while deserving got an Oscar
nomination for Barbie while Greta Gerwig
and Margot Robbie didn't wrote One
outrage fan on X completely proving the
point of the movie in 20 fing 24 you
cannot make this up the social media
user added added referring to the
movie's feminist themes quote wait Ryan
Gosling got nominated for his role as
Ken but Margot Robbie didn't get
nominated for Barbie and gret and gwi
got snubbed for best director way to
justify the literal plot of the movie
wrot another ex-user echoing the theme a
third grous quote if Ryan deserved an N
then Margot certainly did the fact she
didn't uh she wouldn't have won isn't
the point it almost feels like the
academy deliberately played into the
theme of the movie to get people talking
# Oscars haven't been about uh who
actually deserves it for a long time now
indeed there were many expressions of
grief like this someone else wrote I'm
sorry but the straight white guy in
Barbie got nominated and not the actual
women who made the movie all caps now
the award for most melodramatic comment
which was retweeted tens of thousands of
times think had like 30,000 retweets
goes to this comment it said I don't
think men will ever understand how
deeply painful this is a film about
women made by and for women about the
difficulties of being a woman in the
modern patriarchal world and they didn't
even nominate the leading actress or the
female
director yes how painful the Deep
searing pain of watching as a couple of
millionaire women you don't know aren't
nominated for Oscars
well they were nominated for Oscars in
the screenplay and producer categories
but they weren't nominated in the
categories you want which has caused you
unimaginable suffering and pain I mean
you know there are people in this world
today at this very moment who are
malnourished who are homeless who are
starving who are uh dying of horrible
diseases who are watching their family
members die but those people especially
if they're men cannot understand the
depth of pain that this girl on Twitter
must be feeling because Barbie was
snubbed at the Oscars you know it just
it all makes sense meanwhile it goes
without saying that the luminaries over
on Tik Tok jumped on the outrage
bandwagon uh here's just one example
watch no because literally yesterday I
was thinking to myself that if Barbie
got snubbed with margar Robbie not being
in the best actress category or Greta
erig not being in the best um director
category then the point of Barbie is
just like so inyour face at that point I
just checked all of the Oscar
nominations like 5 minutes ago I would
have done it earlier this morning but
obviously I had school but this is
insane like they actually had the balls
to do like they didn't care about public
blacklash or anything like I was
literally thinking to myself the other
day that it would be so funny if they
actually pulled something like this but
I thought to myself there's no way you
know the year of the Barbie movie Barbie
was such a big hit especially in its
messaging I feel like they weren't I
felt like they weren't going to do it
and they did now
I only want to say one thing about that
um it was bad enough when literally
became a filler word that you use three
times in one sentence for no particular
reason but what I can't abide and what I
will not allow I will not allow this new
thing found mostly among genz women
where they begin a sentence with the
words no
because or they put it all together as
she did and make it no because literally
those are three words at the very
beginning of your statement that have
absolutely no meaning in the context and
no reason to be there you are three
words deep into your sentence and you
haven't said anything at all okay you've
said three things already and you've
said
nothing that's an issue for another day
well if you're like me there's not a day
that goes by where you don't call or
text someone you care about uh you know
everyone knows I love talking my
favorite thing is to talk on the phone I
do it constantly my friends of pure talk
are making it easier and more affordable
to connect with the most important
people in your life pure talk gives you
phenomenal coverage on America's Most
dependable 5G Network it's the same
coverage you know and love but for half
the price of the other guys with
unlimited plans starting at just 20
bucks a month the average family saves
almost $1,000 a year as a veteran-owned
company Pur talk raised $10 million
towards veteran debt last year alone
what's more well Pur Talk customer
service team is located right here in
the US and they can help you make the
switch in as little as 10 minutes so I
challenge you to stand with a company
that Champions your values today and
also by the way provides an excellent
service but you got to go to Pur
talk.com Walsh and right now you'll save
an additional 50% off your first month
that's Pur talk.com Walsh to save on
wireless with a company you could be
proud to spend your money with again Pur
talk.com Walsh anyway the media uh
jumped onto the bandwagon 2 Scott feberg
at The Hollywood Reporter had this to
say though Gerwig and Robbie are
nominated in other categories for
writing and producing and though Barbie
did receive eight nominations including
best picture the Optics of excluding the
women most responsible for a critically
acclaimed film that became the biggest
Blockbuster of 2023 from the directing
and lead actress categories are not good
yes those Optics those Optics are very
bad and and when awards are given to
pieces of art the most important thing
to consider is
Optics now one thing is for sure Ryan
Gosling is worried about the Optics
which is why he a co-star in the film
wrote a lengthy statement all but
apologizing for being nominated for his
own performance quote I'm extremely hon
honored to be nominated by my colleagues
alongside such remarkable artists in a
year of so many great films and I never
thought I'd be saying this but I'm also
incredibly honored and proud that it's
for portraying a plastic doll named Ken
but there is no Ken without Barbie and
there is no Barbie without uh movie
without gret Gerwig and Margo Robbie the
two people most responsible for this
history-making globally celebrated film
no recognition would be possible for
anyone on the film without their talent
grit and genius to say that I'm
disappointed that they are not nominated
their respective categories would be an
understatement their work should be re
recogniz along with every other uh along
with the other very deserving nominees
now soon after that statement was posted
America Ferrera another co-star
nominated for her role in the film
posted something similar now of course
the fact that America Ferrera a woman
was nominated would seem to greatly
undercut the sexism angle and the fact
that Margot Robbie wasn't nominated for
best actress because five other women
were nominated for the award what also
seem to undermine the efforts to tie
this to misogyny like in fact in general
anytime you're saying that a woman was
not nominated for best
actress because of sexism there's always
going to be a problem there assuming
that the category is still filled with
other women now if we get to the point
where there are five nominees for best
actress and they're all uh trans
identified males then you'd have a point
although that will also be hilarious and
that will eventually happen but anyway
that's you know that's all the case if
you care about making sense which most
of these people don't in fact Gerwig
wasn't nominated for best director but a
woman named Justine treat who directed
something called anatomy of a fall was
nominated so the claim here is that
Gerwig and Robbie were denied
nominations as part of a sexist
conspiracy even though they both were
nominated in other categories and other
women who are not Gerwig and Robbie were
nominated in the categories that Gerwig
and Robbie were
denied now obviously trying to connect
this to patriarchy and sexism is yet
another delusional and desperate attempt
by very bored and very shallow people to
feel persecuted because they don't know
how to find any meaning in life except
through a false personal narrative of
victimization you know that's that's
what's clearly going on here and that's
the obvious part of the story but the
other part which should be even more
obvious is that the Barbie movie does
not deserve to be nominated for anything
in the first place okay I haven't seen
it I don't plan to seen it but even
without seeing it I know that the movie
is basically trash I 100% know that it's
a fact like I cannot be wrong and I'm
not even saying I'm not worried about
the wokeness I'm not worried about the
feminism the ideological stuff I'm not
saying it because of any of that what I
do know for an absolute fact is that a
film produced by the Mattel toy company
for the primary purpose of selling
Mattel
merchandise cannot be and is not a
towering artistic
achievement okay you could try to find
whatever deep meaning you want in the
Barbie movie but it is without question
primarily a giant toy commercial that is
why the film exists it's why Mattel made
$125 million in additional sales in the
first few months after the Barbie movie
came out sales for Barbie dolls and
another Mattel brand doll uh you know
brand dolls were were up 25% that was
the fundamental point of the movie to
advertise and sell their merchandise and
it succeeded greatly on that front so
all the debates about what is this movie
really mean what's it all about what are
they trying to say what they're trying
to say is buy a Barbie doll that's what
they're trying to say like that's the
message okay that's it and that's why
Mattel is now planning movies based on
Hot Wheel cars and poly pocket and
Rockham sockum robots somehow Uno cards
are going to get their own movie
now so as the superhero movie epidemic
finally starts to
Wayne and and you might feel like you
could finally breathe a s of relief and
maybe we'll get some real films finally
we'll get back to making real Cinema
actual movies actual art you know um but
no because now it appears that the the
Marvel Universe will be supplanted by
the Mattel
Universe thanks to all you people who
pretended that a toy commercial was high
Art here's the fact of the matter no
film that exists primarily to promote a
brand can ever be good that's why all
the Marvel movies suck because they all
exist just to promote the Marvel Brand
that's it that's why they're
there they it can't even be a real film
it can only be at best a very well-made
and technically impressive
commercial so you Barbie fans should be
quiet calm down calm yourself and be
grateful for the absurdly overblown
accolades that the Barbie movie has
already received it didn't deserve any
of them the movie is garbage and that is
why both the film and its fans are
today
cancelled thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast